l'ambiance était lourde hier soir du
côté de la salle Grenon à Tours les
volleyeurs du TVB se sont inclinés face
à Friedrich chafen 3 7 à 0 une des fêtes
en match à la qui condamne les
partenaires de Gary Chauvin à l'emporter
en match retour mercredi prochain en
Allemagne sinon ce sera la fin de leur
parcours en Ligue des Champions retour
sur les minutes qui ont fait basculer le
match avec les la Turquie
soirée difficile ce mercredi agronomes
le tour volley-ball s'incline face à
Friedrich Hafen 3 7 à 0 les ennuis
commencent déjà avant même le début du
match le capitaine du TVB zelkokovic se
blesse à l'échauffement quelques minutes
avant le coup d'envoi c'est donc le
passeur Gary Chauvin qui prend sa place
au pied levé
que je prenne la le relais tout de suite
sans trop réfléchir c'est une déception
parce que on n'est pas très très loin
mais on n'arrive pas à aller au bout des
7 en particulier le premier j'aurais pu
nous mettre dans une spirale un peu
positive et faire un peu oublier à cette
blessure du début du match on a très
bien joué au début du premier siècle
puis on craque un premier set qui fort
pour les tours enjaux pourtant l'équipe
allemande recolle vite au score et finit
par mener la danse l'espoir revient avec
ce point signé Aboubacar Dramé et un ace
de Derio maiko le TVB reprend l'avantage
jusqu'à 23-21 mais ne conclut pas et
friedréchafen remporte ce premier set 25
à 23 concours un peu après le score
pendant le 7 mais à la fin on est au
coup d'accoude et bon sur quelques
imprécisions ça bascule en leur faveur
on leur a mis beaucoup de pression et
des fois on les faisait revenir dans le
match en les soulagé quoi les deuxièmes
et troisième set se suivent et se
ressemblent avec à chaque fois le même
résultat les hommes de Marcello
francoviak battus 25 à 21
parce qu'on il avait une possibilité
à chaque fois on revient à l'histoire
c'est le moment de supposer un peu de
réessayer de récupérer les corps les
esprits c'est une enchaînement très dure
pour nous en ce moment je pense qu'on a
les moyens de d'aller en Allemagne et de
faire beaucoup mieux qu'on a fait
aujourd'hui les tours en joues vont
devoir mettre les bouchées doubles
mercredi 15 février date du match retour
décisif jouer en Allemagne il faudra
battre Friedrich Hafen 3-0 ou 3 1 pour
espérer se qualifier en quart de finale
de la Ligue des Champions